diets can be hard to follow and some of
them don't even work well Dr Nash and
Total Transformation the sponsors of
this next segment have a solution take a
look when I started with Dr Nash I
weighed over 300 pounds and I was
pre-diabetic since being on her program
I lost over 130 pounds and I no longer
have that pre-diabetic threat Dr Nash
Laura's transformation her weight loss
it's unbelievable I want to start off
this week I have some stats here on
diets and weight loss that I want you to
unpack first okay okay the average
American woman goes on six to eight
diets a year in 12 months 96 of people
gain back the weight after doing a
traditional diet and for 80 percent of
people tracking calories and exercise
does not cause permanent weight loss
your program works you went through a
big weight loss Journey how did
everything work for you
so I actually discovered this on my own
because I was overweight since I was
eight years old and I had done diet
after diet I'd probably easily done 36
different types of diets chasing weight
loss but never really seeing a decent
result or a result that would stick and
the diet the doctors could never find
anything wrong so there was always this
message that it was my behavior it was
my willpower I just needed to try harder
but after I became a chiropractor I
actually was able to do my own testing I
found out that I was pre-diabetic with a
fatty liver and when I focused on
reversing the damage that's when I lost
the 80 pounds all right you talk about
focusing on the damage don't most dice
has come down to eating less and moving
more okay you would think so right
because that just sounds like it's
logical but it's not biological and so
no in fact most commercial diets are
going to encourage the problem to worsen
by using tactics like eat what you want
and still lose weight or providing
lifetime memberships in their program
grams which means they're building the
failure right into the technique and
then they push deprivation and TR and
tactics that rely on Willpower and
motivation and the problem is that never
works long term and that's just what
they want they want you to lose weight
not hold a normal weight so this way you
come back to them and you use their
program again that's eye-opening right
there that is eye-opening how is your
program different then my program is
different in three ways so yes we do get
the body to lose weight but we're not
just focused on losing weight we're
focused on burning body fat primarily on
using strategies for fat loss the second
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to customize that program to
Target that person's underlying issues
that's driving the weight problem to be
stubborn and then the third thing that
we actually do is we prove to the client
that their body will hold the weight
loss while they are eating two to three
thousand calories a day if that program
cannot prove to you that your body will
hold the weight loss afterwards then
it's probably a temporary program I'm JC
and every week you bring a special what
do you have to first this week Dr Nash
so normally when I do the one-on-one
evaluation because we do have to figure
out what's going on that's driving that
stubborn weight problem that's 97 but
whenever Las Vegas now allows me to come
on and talk to JC and talk to you guys
always want to do something special so
we have 10 spots available they are 9.97
for that online evaluation it is online
they sell out quickly so get your spot
now but let me see what's going on
inside that body that's stopping you not
only from losing weight but holding a
normal weight
thanks again to Total Transformation for
sponsoring this segment Las Vegas now